yeah but we're smoke different it's
different yeah it's just non-stop you
smoke a little bit where's had me high
for a couple days [__] with me
because he ain't just you know I mean
like you do the shrooms with which you
do the nah we did the uh dab oh the
water bong yeah the water the water
thing yeah that flip [__] yeah flip over
and all that so I was he had me high for
a couple days you say you stopped why
did you quit doing shrooms I had some
bad trips bro like I ain't going front I
probably would [__] with it but it's I
feel like shrooms is based on your
environment bro yeah like I'm taking
shrooms in Harlem not a good place to do
her like it's mad [__] around me and I
took this [__] on Fright Night shout out
to Javonte you know I'm saying my
brother I'm watching the fight it's it's
like 50 people around me it's a bad move
[__] won't take pictures [__] taking
shots it's weed there's a lot going on
and I'm shrimped up I don't know where
I'm at did you have a bad trip I just
sent it I ain't enjoying you freaking
out I was annoyed you know what I'm
saying I was so annoyed with the shroom
I felt like I was supposed to just been
chilling